ça y est après des jours de suspense le
gouvernement a parlé la sentence est
tombée
les hôtes france l'île de france l'eure
la seine maritime et les alpes-maritimes
sont de nouveau confiné pour une période
minimum de quatre semaines à compter de
ce soir minuit
de nouvelles mesures de freinage massive
de l'épidémie interviendront pour quatre
semaines
un confinement un peu particulier
puisqu'il conserve un couvre-feu qui est
tout de même repoussé à 19 heures et il
est possible de sortir
en effet chaque jour en glissant une
attestation il est possible de sortir
sans limite de temps jusqu'à 19h à 10
kilomètres autour de son domicile
une formule aménagé pour permettre aux
français qui vivent dans des petites
surfaces de prendre l'air
si nombreux sont ceux qui acceptent
cette nouvelle règle certains ont montré
leur désapprobation refusant de se
recombiner on en a ras-le-bol est ce
qu'on va continuer à vivre comme ça
jusqu'à la fin des temps pourtant
tellement impuissant quoi une
désobéissance civile qui peut être puni
par la loi mais qui montrent un réel
ras-le-bol de certains concitoyens sur
twitter le hashtag je ne confierais pas
été énormément partager alors comprenez
vous les français qui refusent de se
recombiner comprenez vous les français
qui refusent de se re confiné alors on a
avec nous ce soir
jean frédéric poisson merci d'être là
merci à vous je suis tellement avec
laurent alexandre coeff on a passé un
moment fabuleux tous les deux donc voila
merci alors c'est vous qui est à
l'initiative aussi de de cette affaire
on a gan moix mon ami qu'elle s'était
bien btp hier oui j'ai vu l'émission
laurent alexandre merci d'être là vous
allez nous éclairer là dessus et prisca
thévenoud une autre porte parole de la
république en marche merci d'être là ça
va alors vous savez sur notre bateau
je sais pas si vos confrères vos petits
collègues où l'on dit ça y va
voilà donc mais merci merci d'être là
alors confinement 7 jours sur 7 pour
quatre semaines en ile de france et dans
les autres france dès vendredi soir
minuit 16 départements touchés alors
vous vous dites jean frédéric poisson on
ne se confine rap à vous appeler les
gens à ne pas se recombiner qu'est ce
que vous en pensez tient chez vous
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ici alors vous est ce que vous comprenez
les français qui refusent de se
recombiner et vous vous en faites partie
le ce gouvernement est désespérant il
est incapable de gérer cette crise
sanitaire
l'exaspération la rage des français sont
sont palpables en même temps qu'une
espèce de désespoir de désemparement et
je les comprends parce que en dehors de
tout ce qu'on peut dire sur les chiffres
des existants bien entendu même s'il y
aurait beaucoup de choses à dire sur la
réalité de ces chiffres là de malades de
contaminer et si terrain moi ce que je
vois
avant tout c'est ces jeunes étudiants
qui finissent par devenir complètement
maboul parce qu'ils passent la journée
chez eux ces commerçants qui vont
refermer et qui pour beaucoup d'entre
eux ne reparaîtront pas parce que leur
commerce va disparaître toutes ces
entreprises qui vont mourir tous ces
gens qui sont en télétravail qui
finissent par peser mes mots qu'au fond
ce confinement ne sert pas à grand chose
à la désobéissance
oui oui mais un petit un petit exemple
que je prend rapidement on a entendu
parler de ces trois tgv médicalisé qui
aurait dû rouler et cette semaine ils ne
sont pas partis pourquoi parce qu'il y
avait pas assez de monde à mettre dedans
et la raison c'est que les familles ont
refusé de voir les membres de leur
famille qui pouvait être emmenés dans
des hôpitaux en province ils ont refusé
cet éloignement et je me dis voilà ces
actes là qui sont des contestation
pacifique
normal elles sont juste sur le plan
éthique sont des résistances à la
politique du gouvernement et je trouve
ça très bien et pourvu que ça continue
mais gilles verdez tombé des nues
l'action j'attendais les ché alors je
rappelle six ans frédéric loison
président la voix du président de la
boad et peuvent donc candidat à la
présidentielle 2022 alors messieurs en
responsabilité ce que vous dites est non
seulement démagogique mais c'est
dangereux vous appelle à la
désobéissance civile vous appelez à
l'illégalité mais soit la souffrance et
elle est réelle réel est partagé par
tout le monde soit à ce moment là il n'y
a plus d'esprit collectif c'est l'ère de
l'individualisme et la république
française dont vous devriez partager les
valeurs c'est que on obéit à la loi on
obéit au gouvernement s'il n'ya plus de
règles monsieur je suis effaré par vos
propos alors benjamin castaldi aussi par
exemple bien sûr évidemment et puis
surtout honnêtement la matin on n'est
plus à faire des discours il est à
chaque fois qu'un politique sur ce
plateau ce qui moi ce qui me rend fou
c'est que à chaque fois vous ramener ce
qu'on vit en faisant une campagne et ça
franchement je vous le dis ça devrait
exercer raïssa d insulte insupportable
et bien que soit vous et c'est toujours
de thierry couverture et expliqué que
vous
on refait le match alors il reparle des
masques et oui effectivement il ya plein
de gars qui ont qu on a tous vécu mais
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est
ce que vous proposez
comme d'habitude à rien donc maintenant
il va falloir qu'on se serre les coudes
tous ensemble qu'on arrête de faire de
la polémique de tirer la couverture
décès de gratter des voix à gauche ou à
droite ou aux extrêmes et moi
franchement aujourd'hui on doit être
ensemble et pas à dire à mme ne fallait
pas voir s'il fallait pas plus à
proposer autre chose je fais du bon
boulot s'est par la suite je suis pas
venu en forçant la porte
non on l'a invité
deuxièmement vous m'invitez parce que je
suis un responsable politique qui vont
bien sûr en troisièmement en
l'occurrence dont troisièmement je suis
désolé de vous dire que il ya tellement
d'incohérences dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire c'est ça que je voudrais
pointait aussi
deuxièmement il ya tellement
d'impossibilité de débattre sur le fond
en vérité sur la vérité de la situation
il ya plein d'éléments jeu pas d'appeler
le fond le griffon le fond de quoi elle
ne veut pas et bayer du fond c'est quoi
le fond la vérité quoi effrayer nous qui
ôta et dans le fond de quoi ah mais
c'est la vérité sur la stratégie
vaccinale c'est la vérité sur les
chiffres de réanimation c'est on est en
train de faire croire aux français que
le confinement était inéluctable
alors je reconnais pas c'est ce que nous
disait l'herbe et roger b 0-2 pension
soit vrai jean-frédéric protéger le
droit de considérer qu'il ya d'autres
solutions
jean-frédéric il a fallu faire autrement
qu'il n'est pas trop tard pour faire
autour de quoi on va voir ce qu'elle dit
dans ces échanges entre et jean frédéric
poisson oui juste c'est ce que nous
disait hier m e mail ou mettre des
visions hier sur ce plateau il a même
quitté le plateau hier parce qu'il dit
que mon beauf les chiffres de la
réanimation mais je vois pas la terre
alors justement je me tourne vers
laurent alexandre j'y reviens ici liste
est ce que cette théorie est plausible
noms et les complotistes d'accord il est
délirant d'imaginer que les médecins m
en réanimation des malades qui ne
doivent pas y être
quand on sait à quel point c'est
désastreux d'être en réanimation
on souffre énormément en réanimation
c'est un endroit très très difficile on
est en réanimation que des malades
extrêmement sévère donc prétendre que
nous médecins extrait pour emmerder le
gouvernement omet des malades qui ne
devrait pas être en réanimation en
réanimation personne c'est délirant
comme c'est insultant que le corps
médical s'est mutuellement scandaleux
donc à un moment où faut arrêter ces
propos délirants
mais un médecin ne ferait souffrir un
malade en le mettant à tort en
réanimation ce sont des propos
diffamatoires et scandales qui ont été
tenus alors juste quand vous entendez
donc que c'est on manipule les chiffres
voilà que les chiffres sont fous des
rénovations c'est n'importe quoi c'est
n'importe quoi et quand on est médecin
et qu'on a fait de la réa et qu'on a vu
jusqu'à une réa on n'imagine pas une
seconde qu'on puisse mettre exprès en
réanimation à malades qui ne méritent
pas d'y être parce que la réa c'est
vraiment très très c'est nécessaire pour
les malades qui sont graves mais c'est
un endroit où on souffre beaucoup quand
on est malade et on y met que les
malades qui est vraiment nécessite une
réanimation personne ne dise à dr et
certainement pas moi
qu'est ce que vous dites alors et sur
les chiffres je dis simplement que je
constate qu'il ya beaucoup d'hôpitaux
privés dans lesquels des lits sont
disponibles on les utilise pas pourquoi
il y à des hôpitaux des services de
réanimation à l'hôtel-dieu par exemple
ont été démantelés ya peu de temps dont
les équipements sont encore parfaite
vente actifs et utilisables personne ne
les utilisent pour quoi et si donc il y
a dans beaucoup d'endroits en france des
hôpitaux des centres hospitaliers qui
pourrait accueillir des malades en aval
la réanimation par exemple puisque
malheureusement quand il ya assez peu de
lui-même ce qui pourrait avoir des
traitements un peu plus légers restent
dans les services de ré aujourd'hui
pascal place on pourrait d'étendre ses
services
et lorsque j'entends et je comprends
comme nous tous au fond c'est à cause de
cette tension sur les services de
réanimation conre confine sûr il ya des
moyens de détendre ça en amont avec des
traitements en aval avec de la
répartition alors sur des services qui
sont inoccupés comprend si le
confinement c'est à cause de ça
pardonnez moi c'est une très mauvaise
décision est politique on a bien compris
alors comprenez vous les français qui
refusent de se confiner et aux jantes on
vous dit oui moi déjà je pense que ce re
confinement local il crée un sentiment
d'injustice ya seulement un tiers des
français qui sont confinés donc à des
gens à paris en ile de france ou dans le
nord ils vont se dire pourquoi dans le
sud ils sont pas confinés et moi je suis
confiné donc ils vont sortir versement
ensuite le confinement au sens propre
cerf qui consiste à rester 100% du temps
enfermé chez soi il est inhumain il est
intenable
donc qu'est-ce que les gens vont faire
ils ont grugé lui confère des fausses
attestations
ils vont sortir ils vont aller chez
norma
ça c'est une infime là là c'est pas du
c'est de ça qu'on est jeunes on parle de
gens qui disent comprenez vous les
français qui refusent de s'entraîner oui
je sais qu'ils feront pas de nom mais
qui feront pas des fausses attestations
d'oussalah rsa c'est mieux non mais ça
n'a rien à voir c'est des gens qui dit
ou alors qu'il arrière chaucer et puis
voilà ouvertement je sors là vous êtes
hors sujet guillaume excusez moi
monsieur norbert guillot je comprends
les gens qui vont pas gruger ou pas
gruger
je comprends les gens qui vont sortir
alors que c'est interdit parce que je
trouve que c'est insupportable
le vrai en fait tout le monde respecte
le confinement quand ça les arrange le
vrai confinement comme on l'a vécu en
mars dernier qui consiste à rester 100%
du temps chez soi déjà ya très peu de
gens qui le font et ceux qui le font les
pauvres c'est insupportable d'accord
mais c'est quand même ce qui a permis à
un nombre donné de libérer des places en
réanimation est ce que vous dites
monsieur oui moi je suis je suis désolé
mais c'est de l'opportunisme politique
parce que vous dites on nous ment alors
y'a aucun mensonge lorsque vous avez dit
savait pas répondu on nous ment sur quoi
je viens de lire mais faites le fait non
c'est pas du mensonge c'est juste mais
c'est pas dur elle songe donc mais
faites attention à ce que vous dites si
vous êtes responsables politiques parce
qu'en l'occurrence aujourd'hui la seule
solution ce serait que tout le monde
soit vacciné vous savez que ça ne va pas
être possible
donc à un moment donné je préfère un
confinement d'un mois sélectionné en
semi confinement c'est la plus grande
crise sociale psychologique que vit la
france en ce moment elle intègre photo à
être confiné commenté conseil et là on a
la chance à tous de sortir de chez nous
de voir des
le soir je reproche moi je dis que c'est
facile comme on a la chance de paix
civile et la civilité je me confesse
qu'il cédait la démagogie ce que tu dis
nous on veut sortir ben oui c'est vrai
va pas de soi oui il ya des impacts
seront fine et c'est un supporter mais
l'agression ckoi et parce que dire non
ça sert à me dire oui ou non à la
question et vous qu'est ce qu'on vit
depuis un an un bordel dangereux caisse
quelques et apparemment je pas médecin
enfin moi jouer après il ya division des
autres qui disent le contraire mais
globalement dans le monde entier donc
dans l'intégrité du monde
ceux qui ont confiné ont à peu près
réussi à s'en sortir donc pourquoi non
il faudra que le vrai confinement comme
on l'a vécue il ya un an il est
insupportable injustice caprice ktm et
oui je me permets soit en allant battre
l'egypte risque on n'est pas en train de
dire justement le confinement qu'on a
vécu il ya un an et on est en train de
faire en sorte de pâles revivre parce
que ça serait insupportable et parce que
ça fait au nom qu'on est dans une crise
sanitaire
donc là le but c'est effectivement de
dire oui la situation est extrêmement
préoccupante extrêmement grave dans
certains territoires et de faire en
sorte que les mesures comprennent ne
reviennent pas à avoir plus de
conséquences dramatiques sur le mental
des français dont b justement pris ce
cas vous vous comprenez les gens qui
disent non ressent peu plus voilà je ne
vais pas me confiner parce que il ya
plein de gens on va pas se mentir il ya
des restaurateurs il ya des gens qui
travaillent qui travaillent pour des
discothèques qui travaille dans
l'événementiel qui sont fermés depuis
des mois et des mois et des mois qu'il
faut rentrer il faut entrer 0 euros ils
se disent on ne voit pas le bout du
tunnel on va encore on être confiné
quatre semaines
on n'en peut plus là on a à ses hobbies
on n'en peut plus on va sortir et on va
même pas respecté ce que nous dit le
gouvernement est ce que vous comprenez
ces gens mais bien sûr que ça se
comprend et ça s'entend complètement
parce qu'on n'en peut plus on en a tous
marre maintenant il faut pas oublier
qu'un certain nombre de dettes qui sont
là je peux entendre que c'est pas ce
n'est pas la panacée parce que les gens
veulent juste reprendre une vie normale
et travailler et gagner leur vie en
travaillant
mais encore une fois et moi c'est ça que
je reviens parce que ça revient et
encore il ya une différence entre j'en
peux plus j'en ai marre et faire de la
désobéissance civile qui sont pour moi
deux choses complètement opposées vous
disais tout à l'heure on m'invite sur le
plateau je suis désolé de le dire mais à
mon avis aussi on vous invite parce que
vous avez ce genre de propos c'est
complètement le jeu the subs c'est
complètement les jours vous les assumez
mais maintenant moi aussi je vous le dis
c'est complètement à l'uci
de vouloir prétendre à la candidature de
2022 en disant clairement je refuse de
protéger les français
donc je sais pas ce que je dis mais pas
si donc en disant j'appelle à la chose
est possible
exact le confinement trop donc la
désobéissance civile sur ina.fr c'est
que vous mettez dans votre salon vous la
faites vous faites un seul filet et ça
ira très bien
mais dire mais dire que les hôpitaux
c'est complètement farfelu ce qui s'y
passe etc
je vous invite à y aller je vous invite
à y aller je vous invite à parler aux
familles endeuillées mail que trois
points mais on n'est pas tous les jours
cda bas qu'est ce que vous leur dites
alors finalement elle les amis restez
chez vous ça va aller mais enfin
franchement il ya quelque chose qui est
quand même terrible dans ce dans cette
très grande difficulté à avoir un débat
rationnel sur ces questions c'est ça qui
me surprend le plus je vous dis depuis
tout à l'heure et je le répèterai parce
que et encore une fois j'assume
complètement
moi je comprends que un commerçant à qui
on demande de faire mieux aujourd'hui en
ile-de-france et dans quelques autres
départements régions de france qui
depuis un an a fait tout ce qu'on lui a
demandé de faire qui sait parfaitement
organiser les flux dans son magasin qui
sait parfaitement faire patienter les
gens dehors comme ça se fait dans toutes
les boulangeries de france et de navarre
les marchands de chemises etc
il est boulanger resteront ouvertes les
marchands chemise non fermée pour qu'on
lui demande de fermer
à quoi ça sert et qu'est ce que ça a
comme impact sur la santé publique de
l'empêcher d'ouvrir son magasin alors
que c'est vrai qu'en respectant toutes
les règles
l'imsa enfin bon ça c'est sûr ça on en a
parlé pas mal de fois jean frédéric
poisson
c'est vrai que je vous dire et les
magasins de vêtements les magasins voilà
de jouer où je sais pas franchement on
aimerait pour eux que ce soit la folie
toute la journée qu'ils aient 40
personnes
toute la journée chez eux qu'ils soient
dans le magasin en train de choisir des
fringues bras mais quand il ya deux
trois cinq personnes au même moment
c'est déjà
c'est déjà beaucoup donc il ya deux mois
que vous êtes vous dit vous comprenez
les français qui refusent de se
recombiner ce que vous vous allez refusé
je vais mettre de l'eau dans mon vin
pour une raison simple c'est que le
confinement comme il ya un an j'étais
farouchement contre mais là un
confinement vous pouvez sortir tout ouïe
dehors il là je trouve que vraiment ce
serait démagogique que de dire que c'est
pas une bonne mesure on peut aller
dehors
j'avais très peur moi quand je serai en
forme totalement pourquoi parce que je
reçois un nombre considérable aller vers
ces marchés
pour martin jeunes qui sont dans une
détresse abyssal non mais oh j'aurais
bien juste juste moi moyens si c'est que
cette fois c'est l'avocat du diable là
dessus allez dehors d'accord donc ça
veut dire qu'on va avoir des
attroupements
on va discuter entre avril au contraire
et robert pas marcher seul comme des
mots non non non au contraire souvenez
vous de l'époque car maintenant expliqué
chris massie reid souvenez vous de
l'époque où on ne pouvait sortir qu
entre 18h et 19h là on avait tout le
monde au même endroit au même moment sur
panon joggé et il sortait au moment là
comme on a toute la journée va pouvoir
diluer les sorties d'une journée et le
fait de pouvoir s'ils voulaient
psychologiquement sorte savoir vous
devez sortir de chez vous à n'importe
quelle heure du jour la nuit pour une
durée indéfinie qu'à 19h mais pour une
durée indéterminée
ça change tout c'est pas un vrai
compliment moi je pense à et commerçants
la mairie
non mais attendez moi je ne suis pas par
là pour parler de commerçants c'est
dramatique je suis pas là pour parler
c'est ça des jeunes qui me des jeunes
des lycéens des collégiens des gens de
des désillusions en faculté à plein de
gens gagnent qui ont dit sur confinement
il y aura un rôle pouvoir sortir toute
la journée mais il ya des ombres fertois
non mais ça c'est pas bon on va tourner
sa prose as ça permet à chacun d'avoir
une vie intérieure un peu plus riches
que de ne pas consommer pendant quelques
mois j'ai pas de l'intérieur c'est quoi
alors c'est que la vie intérieure
commence pas précisément au moment où
pensez pas en avoir enfin et je crois
que d'une certaine manière pas de
consumérisme pendant quelques semaines
on peut serrer la ceinture c'est
terrible pour l'instant je veux dire je
suis favorable à un confinement
intelligent et ça c'est presqu'un
déconfinement comme un confinement ciron
pourrait jouer sur les mots en disant
que c'est un début de déconfinement ou
que c'est un début de confinement
laisser les deux pour moi le confinement
drastique il était redoutable pour les
étudiants qui obtiendront n'appelez pas
les suivre j'appelle les gens à
respecter cette forme de confinement ça
oui il faudrait 50 cm sur 2 2 a rejoint
mais même sur cette place confinement
drastique donc ça c'est acceptable juste
l'auront long alexandre c'est une bonne
mesure pour vous qu'on n'a pas le choix
d'accord mais le gouvernement a
tellement glande et comment l'arrêter en
matière de vaccination vous connaissez
les chiffres la france a vacciné 8% des
français l'angleterre est en train de
dépasser 40%
israël a dépassé 65 % donc ça ils sont
même à 109% pascal deuxième dose sur
l'anneau unique donc on est dans une
situation où on n'a pas le choix si on
ne peut sortir du confinement et des
couvre-feux que par la vaccination
or le gouvernement s'est planté dans sa
stratégie de vaccination puisque la
france vaccine même moins que le maroc
et vaccine cinq fois moins que des pays
comme le chili je ne parle même pas
d'israël donc dans la situation actuelle
on n'a pas le choix
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que si on
veut s'en sortir vite il faut vacciner
faut que le gouvernement arrête de
glander en matière de vaccination
l'ivoirité est plus important il faut
que c'est moins d'injustice sur les
doses vaccinales parce que la réalité du
confit demandé quatre ans et moins c'est
qu'on a donné très peu de doses
vaccinales en ile de france l'île de
france a été à part paris intra muros
l'ile-de-france a été beaucoup moins
vacciner que le reste de la france
comment et bien parce qu'on l'a on a
réparti plus tôt sur la province les
doses vaccinales
quand vous regardez les pourcentages de
vaccination il est beaucoup plus faible
en ile-de-france n'a certainement
banlieue parisienne qu'il est en
province soit on a on a en réalité
vacciner mois en ile de france et si on
reconfirme aujourd'hui c'est parce que
l'île de france a été sacrée pour la
cause d'accidents question en plus juste
parce que moi je vois plein de gens qui
me disent oui on m'a proposé l'astra
seneca et qui se pose la question parce
que là on laisse traîner car aujourd'hui
c'est voilà ça c'est très bien quand
même des métiers 2 j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde
vadocz et speedy est longue mais c'est
tout mon mandat mais personne ne veut le
faire est ce que ça pose vraiment
problème ça le premier ministre
aujourd'hui se vacciner parle
astrazeneca il montre l'exemple
moi si je n'avais pas déjà été vaccinées
par le kaiser je me ferai vacciner pour
donner l'exemple par la strada car si
aucune arrière-pensée mardi avec une
touffe problème c'est que là s'il ya un
délire et que les gens que les gens elle
se faire vacciner par l'astre à 100 sans
hésiter vraiment aujourd'hui c'est
important de le dire on prend moins de
risques à prendre l'astra zenica ne rien
point du cac à ne rien prendre et on le
dit aux téléspectateurs
ça c'est vraiment ce que tout le monde
me dit vraiment je le dis parce que
voilà moi tout m'appelle il faut
absolument se faire vacciner que ce soit
la strack soit nous mieux que rien voilà
donc apparemment je vous le dis il faut
prendre le vaccin et un médecin qui
donne un très bon exemple sur le plateau
de btp hier il disait que sans prendre
de vaccins n'étaient sur l'autoroute en
sens inverse en prenant le vaccin on
était sur l'autoroute avec un excès de
vitesse ah ouais les travées les choses
pas mal c'est pas mal c'était qu'il y
avait désormais fermé de revenir sur les
vaccins sûrs de manière très claire avec
les chiffres
sur le premier trimestre de l'année on a
reçu 100 millions de doses en europe sur
le deuxième trimestre donc qu'on est en
train d'entamer sa va être 300 millions
de doses c'est bien plus que ce qui
était prévu comme les nôtres a encore
tout à fait et le rock assez sceptique
on est au bout du rouleau la cct répété
hier soir 10 millions mi avril 20
minutes c'est très bien et 30 millions
ni juin pas très peu des parts soit sur
lot bon ce vendée vacciner 10 millions
de personnes au 15 avril
on sera au 15 avril moins de la moitié
qu'elle angleterre aujourd'hui donc on
ne rattrape pas le retard ce n'est pas
vrai c'est un mensonge politique le
waterloo vaccinale continue c'est
vraiment que le gouvernement se mette à
bosser prades le western belle fête
octobre huit ans mais non mais après sur
un tube hey calais vacciner pour pas se
faire engueuler sur le waterloo
vaccinale le gouvernement ne cesse de
blanc
c'est dit la vérité castaldi ouais on a
beaucoup parlé sur le astrazeneca qu'il
ya plein de médecin qui avait des listes
un jean à vacciner mais non annulé et
moi j'avais dit à mon médecin si vous
avez une place je la prendrai de
personnes il avait là non je suis prêt
c'est vraiment fini oui je me fais mais
votre tour il arrive qu'on la passe que
[Rires]
l'animal ait plus de 150 la cee
c'est quand ça fait partie de la
génération dont rien ne dit qu'il faut
qu'ils se préparent à partir c'est
toujours le faire tous les mois les
cherry qui se veut active
mavuba dans l attaque siné besoin pour
la peau la rubéole doit aussi les
médecins qui ont des désistements moi je
serais ravi de le faire l'accord très
bien et chérie alors je vous le dis on
voit en fait vous êtes trois à ne pas
appeler à la désobéissance
il ya justement frédéric poisson et qui
est beaucoup plus mesuré je trouve que
ce que j'avais vu voilà vous êtes un
petit bocal meyroune cette fois que je
suis jamais je ne suis pas vacciné je
vais attendre un peu ça alors ce qui se
passe avec ces vaccins parce que
[Applaudissements]